- Now I could not be more excited
than I am for today's show
because it has a theme, a
very strong theme actually.
It's literally been 22
years in the making.
Back in 1999 I was
lucky enough to be in it
and it's just really near
and dear to my heart.
It's 'Never Been Kissed'.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
And today I am actually
reuniting with some of the cast.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Because also, who doesn't love a reunion,
but first in honor of 'Never Been Kissed',
we have a viewer who wrote
in 'Looking for Help in the
Love Department' and Tasha says
that she has never been
kissed by her new boyfriend.
So she's gonna join us now
from the California State baseball field.
Tasha, hello.
- Hey Drew.
So yes, my boyfriend Hunter and I,
we started dating over the
summer during the pandemic
and we actually met five years ago
and essentially we were
dating other people
so we just became really
good friends over the years
and about three months ago,
we decided to take our
relationship to the next level
and now we are official.
So now it's just a matter of
us having this first kiss,
which we have not had yet.
- [Drew] Well, let me just
ask a question that comes
to my mind.
Why has there been no kiss so far?
(crowd laughs)
- Honestly, I feel like we
just have the classic case
of Ross and Rachel Syndrome,
where we've been friends
for so long and now there's
just this big buildup
and we're both so nervous and excited
and we want it to be perfect.
And I sent Hunter a text this
morning, inviting him here.
And I said, you know, 'I
don't want a response.
Just trust me and show up if
you are ready to take this
to the next level and
make it the real deal.'
So I'm here at the pitcher's
mound at Cal State.
I have no idea if he's
gonna show up or not,
but you only live once, right?
(crowd cheers and claps)
- I love this.
This moment is special
and we're all invested
in it with you.
We're gonna check in with you
and let's see if we can create
a happy ending for today.
(crowd clapping and cheering)
At the beginning of the show,
we met Tasha who has asked for help
in the romance department
three months ago.
Tasha's best friend,
Hunter became her boyfriend
and yet she's never been kissed by him.
How perfect is that for our
'Never Been Kissed' reunion.
Now, Tasha has asked Hunter to meet her
on the pitcher's mound at
California State University
if he's ready to make this thing real.
Here's hoping.
Let's check in and see if he's arrived.
(crowd clapping and cheering)
I'm nervous, I'm so invested in this.
Tasha, how are you feeling?
- Pretty nervous, lots of butterflies.
I have no idea if he's gonna show up,
I have a feeling he will.
- Um, this is a fantasy
and yet it's your reality
and we're here to support you and uh wait,
I'm just getting word.
Hunter is there.
(crowd claps and cheers)
( music starts)
(crowd claps and cheers,
music plays in background)
Hi guys.
- We were in the middle of something.
- I'm so happy for you both.
You know, there's um-
- Thank you for making this happen.
- There's an old saying that
some of the best relationships
come out of friendship.
(crowd claps and cheers)
(Tasha speaks inaudibly)
Hunter, how you feel?
- Pretty good.
(crowd laughs)
It was a long time coming, yeah.
- And Tasha, how do you feel?
- Very happy, very thankful.
(crowd clapping and cheering)
- Congratulations on showing
that fantasies can become reality
and thank you for letting us
all be a part of this moment.
We wish you the very best.
Thanks for watching everyone.
Join us tomorrow for
another sunny day in LA
as we bid you good night.
(crowd clapping and cheering)
(upbeat music)